[Music]
joe contains a very important warning
for anyone with photo sensitivity but
forgets to include an additional warning
about eating food while watching the
show and i'm still bitter about my baked
potato turning sour in my mouth during
the final minutes of episode one joe
informs us that the queen is not in
residence but never explores this
further what a tease it's not about
rooms
it's about power
that building has one purpose to say i'm
the queen and you are my subjects but it
also says i'm the queen i need my staff
available so i'm gonna make sure
everyone's close and doesn't need to
drive to work but that doesn't sound
quite as dramatic oh no is that blood
nah show just wants to trick us into
thinking that this is a continuation of
the bloodbath we saw in the last episode
but instead it's just trash from the
burger mart and we all know that fast
food garbage is comprised of 25 meat 25
food containers and 50 catch up
tampering with evidence
clear no you're solid now you were clear
a second ago silly
the animators decided that if they were
going to go through with all the trouble
to draw a dismembered body that it
needed to be shown at least 64 times we
get it they died horrifically sure spray
acquires his corpse down with lube and
attach the doodad to make us think
immortal might survive toy with my
emotions and momentarily tricked me into
thinking the guardians could be saved i
could handle it careful don't bump her
don't bump her she is dead sir her head
has been relocated on its axis bumper
all you want she doesn't give a [ __ ]
about bubs leaving a book on a stove top
this coffee maker is running way too hot
for a traditional drip machine either
there's a wiring problem or omniman is
being addicted to debbie's tongue fifty
percent of the shower is useless space
as the global defense agency we have
access to medical technology far beyond
any normal hospital exposition
ah that's one of our threat response
teams more expose we're not in the mood
for the tour donald oh thank you debbie
this big ass screen is needed to monitor
blood pressure and temperature with just
a little bit of attention to design
economy they could eliminate most of
these other screens i would probably cut
the power usage of this room in half
we're a little understaffed in the hero
department category is things that
should have been said quietly but needed
to be spoken loud enough for someone
else to hear and move the story along
stop
get away from us invincible brings these
half-assed verbal commands to a
firefight that is already in progress oh
[ __ ]
oh my god once you suffer a dislocated
fracture you never get used to seeing
that and since i'm in the driver's seat
i'm sitting that i don't know who you
are but it's time to go well now that a
superhero set a one-liner of sorts the
winning can start we gave legal time to
escape that's what mattered you also
redirected weapons fire from the
civilians on the street to the ones in
the building so really it's all about
perspective
hey
none of these people are paying
attention to where they are walking but
these guys act like mark is the ass for
not yielding to them these guys you and
debbie need a lasagna i make a good one
calling your friend's mom by your first
name rather than mrs grayson also
everyone thinks that their lasagna is
the best but everyone is always wrong
about their lasagna true lasagna has no
ricotta cheese i'm um
invincible
god that sounds dumb when i say it like
that sounds a little optimistic maybe
mark would be excellent at tv since but
eve knocked that one out of the park i'm
adam eve you don't say you are the
superhero that looks exactly like a girl
named eve with hair and eyes the exact
same you don't say
you're the reason todd beat him up again
oh yes blame her for existing i never
recognized you before no one does it's a
psychology thing if you don't expect to
see a superhero in your school you don't
see a superhero in your school i agree
with this every time i think i see a
celebrity on the street i do a double
take stare for a minute realize i've
been staring too long and have to
pretend like i'm looking at birds or
some and even after that i'm unsure if i
just saw a celebrity or not however i
don't think this applies to super
powered individuals who use their
abilities as indiscreetly as adam even
invincible do whether or not expect to
see a person fly away i will definitely
notice that when it happens that's us
everyone's fourth favorite superhero
team wait what the number of superheroes
on this show seems to be increasing
exponentially if there are that many
superhero teams i would start thinking
it's very likely to see a superhero at
your school now i have to retcon these
sins that's much better you'll get used
to it
the fights not the barfing so to be
clear barfing is a thing that people
will never get used to whereas the
fighting dismemberment murder chaos and
death of innocents and baddies alike
will seem very normal she's evil i'm
calling it despite all the details that
went into the articles themselves the
names of these publications are phoned
in and online news is the worst also not
one of these sources ask for permission
to collect cookies they ran off because
they were dying of old age well i will
have to say i saw this romance coming
from a mile away from one giant show to
another mocomade's twitch motto somehow
makes its way into this episode damien
dark blood demon detective show thinks i
used up all my good darkwing duck
material on the first episode but plan a
has and always will be this song three
two one damn in dark blood when there's
trouble you call the double d damian
dark blood let's get dangerous try to
keep up the most frustrating part of
this training montage is that it
completely avoids explaining how
anyone's hair stays tangle free despite
whipping in the wind without being tied
back i once took a jeep ride with the
soft top down it took me three hours to
comb out the tangles and i have a buzz
cut breakfast until 10 43 a.m why not 10
45 why i'm at 10 30. i guess it doesn't
matter because no matter when the cutoff
starts someone will pull up to the
window 10 seconds too late and demand to
have breakfast like an [ __ ]
asking someone to do what they were
already doing the fractions come from a
dimension with a faster temporal rate as
a result the tachyons they emit spin
more rapidly than our own show expects
me not to complete spinning tachyons
with the spinning dna on this monitor
and i simply cannot allow that are you
okay
donald said you saved a lot of lives
yeah it was just uh
harder than i thought i'm glad mrs
grayson is checking in with her son but
wouldn't this have been a conversation
she would have had earlier while
comforting him in the midst of his blood
covered trauma
i'm not gonna sinrack somehow being
annoying during what i assume is his
postcoital celebratory milk drinking but
i am gonna send rex for being one of
those people that drink straight from
the container so you can be more awesome
than him and take his place that's how
dating works it is not
over excessive pen clicking why aren't
they getting old in the previous fight
it took the alien several minutes before
showing signs of aging and the teen team
has shown up at the very beginning of
their newest invasion be patient kids
sheesh teen team starts the battle with
the same unsuccessful tactics as they
did in the last one dupli flip jumps
about letting her copies get massacred
sex load throws his balls at people
zachary quinjet does his best iron man
impersonation and pinky and the lame
makes use for swiss army bubble yum the
only significant difference is that
intolerable discovers the power of
boners so they target the wristband
expertly but what stopped them from
being so precise with their previous
attacks could she not pink spike through
their brains
invincible is a dick to healthcare
workers in the poor bleeding soul that
needed this gauze hey i need my costume
back i don't care how torn up it is it's
classified and i want it back go get it
now these intermittent bouts of
unwarranted hostility raise questions
like maybe nolan has a thyroid problem
also viltra might privilege
breathless human has time for this
wow i get it taking the view while you
can but does does mark not need to
breathe anymore is that part of being
invincible even on their third attempt
these aliens are still opening their
portals across from each other thereby
funneling all their troops into one
easily surrounded location i'm no
military scholar but we all know it's
not fun to keep using the same
predictable positions also the teen team
never once attempts to exploit this
teens rex sleeps from the vehicle here
and can he fly i don't think he can fly
rex is dead and i demand to see the
animation to confirm this i'm sure he's
explaining nicely why they should leave
us alone show makes me cautiously
rethink some of the things my mom has
said to me over the years that i may
have previously misinterpreted to me my
father was not systematically destroying
a civilization the juxtaposition of this
scene against the one where invincible
fights allen clearly establishes the
differences between the two characters
not only in regard to physical ability
but also in the way of desire and
motivation it's a brilliant bit of
storytelling done through action
sequences and without exposition but
also genocide i'm at a loss for how to
report this but the guardians of the
globe are dead
for
sake did we need this eyebrow we already
know he killed them the show just spent
two minutes showing us his ruthlessness
just enjoy hugging your family nolan
same thing we do every night pinky try
to take over the world janet's made a
lot of talk talk into my ear holes about
you michael michael michael kleichel
quickly that's some good meatball boy
freeze guys we get it it's a code red
enough oh hey
it's the iceman i'm just trying to
figure out what are your powers again
you just connected man but that is what
happens when people get into air battles
[Music]